summer break might be coming to a close
but whether you're in school or not
there's another batch of free games
coming for Xbox Live Gold members if
you're one of them and want to know what
you can play in September I've got you
covered
and don't forget to hit that subscribe
button to be the first to know about the
games with gold lineup every month
first up Xbox one is getting Fortson
motorsport 5 game of the year edition
that means you're getting the main game
and the top gear Car Pack which includes
ten cars handpicked by the previous
hosts of the smash hit BBC show forts of
five might seem like an odd choice with
four to seven on the horizon but think
of it as a nice preview it'll be
available all month long also coming to
Xbox one is oxen-free this narrative
adventure game puts you in the shoes of
teenager Alex as she and her friends
explore an abandoned and possibly
haunted Island it gets pretty trippy and
thanks to the game's dynamic dialogue
choices every adventure on the island is
different oxen-free will be available
from September 16th through October 15
on the 360 side you can grab Hydro
Thunder hurricane if you've played the
original arcade game Hydro Thunder
you'll feel right at home with this
console sequel for the uninitiated this
racing game lets you choose one of nine
boats and speed and jump your way
through ridiculous courses like Atlantis
and the Bermuda Triangle
you can jump in from September 1st
through the 15th and for the shooter
fans out there you can also grab
battlefield 3 while the current
battlefield flavor is world war 1 this
entry in the series is set in the
current day with missions and maps
located around the world in places like
Iran and New York City if you're looking
for a competitive multiplayer fix you
can enlist from September 16th through
the 30th and don't forget that both 360
games are also playable on Xbox one
thanks to backwards compatibility and
those are your free games with gold for
September 2017 you can always check out
gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles over at GameSpot and if you want
to keep up with all of our top stories
you can grab the official game spot now
app on iOS and Android
[Music]